good morning
uh tell us then just a little bit about
your your national food strategy i
suspect there will be
some in whitehall who might do a sir
humphrey appleby and describe it as bold
well it's it's intended to be both a
manifesto
and a strategic plan the the food system
our country is a miracle and a disaster
we saw it in covet
food companies worked to get us food but
also it was a huge factor in
what was killing people and we need to
create a food system that is good for us
and good for the planet and we recommend
we say that you need to do
four things you need to break the junk
food cycle to protect the nhs
we need to reduce health inequality
we need to use our land better and we
need to change
our food culture in the long term well
let's talk about the
the the junk foods aspect of the
strategy and of course plenty people
have
have happened upon the the tax that
you're proposing on on sugar and
salt what evidence says though that the
costs that would be
the costs in those circumstances would
just simply not be passed on to
consumers who
prefer their food to be a little bit
saltier and sugar shoot more sugary
well i think the first question is why
have attacks at all everyone thinks in
this country that
the primal mode of thinking is that the
way to solve
uh obesity and diet related disease is
through education exercise and willpower
and people who don't have the willpower
by corollary deserve what is inflicted
upon them but actually none of that's
true
exercise did not help you lose weight
it's brilliant in many ways but it
doesn't help you lose weight
and there is a strong genetic component
in some people that makes them
particularly
attracted to these foods companies
marketed at them they eat more companies
spend more money on it and you need to
break that commercial cycle and that's
what the traxxas intended to do
and there's a lot of evidence from the
reformula it's a reformulation tax in
sugar and salt
there's a lot of evidence from sugary
drinks that it'll that they'll
reformulate rather than pass on the cost
from mexico from hungary so we are
confident that this is a tax that will
take out the worst make the worst foods
uh a bit better for people it's not
enough on its own but it is
uh it is it is necessary to make the
transformation
yeah i i mean presumably the other
aspect to it is people
preparing their own low fat low sugar
low salt meals to go along with not not
eating the junk food but
you know that does require time and in a
society such as ours how likely is it
that people
getting home after a long day at work
are going to spend a half hour the hour
of the hour and a half it might take to
prepare that meal
rather than just reaching into the
freezer
yeah well i think you're right it does
take time and it takes skills
and it's a long term transition we've
put in place a recommendation for a huge
education package
on uh cookery and nutrition because
we've lost the skills through three
generations
and that's why you know that is going to
take time we eat more processed food
than any other country in europe about
50
compared to 14 in italy and we need to
shift that and eat more unprocessed food
cook more fruit and veg
but we can't wait for that transition
which is why we need to make the
processed food the worst food
better for us the the strategy mr
dimbley was widely trained
skills skills sorry to interrupt sorry
turns over the
the the um the uh the strategy as
advertised as pre-built
certainly people were expecting to see
quite a lot in in about
reducing the amount of of meat that we
eat i was speaking with someone from the
national farmers union just a little bit
earlier on today
they made the point that actually what
you're suggesting is less of the junk
meat rather than you know the steaks and
the beefy bakes that i'm particularly
fond of
yeah there is there is about six
chapters
of of 16 on meat it's a very very
complicated
topic and uh not all meat is equal we
need to reduce our meat eating by about
30
we cannot meet our carbon targets or our
nature targets
unless we do that it just takes up too
much land but there is a way of doing
that by cutting out the process stuff
and and keeping the roast chicken the
steak the things that we really enjoy so
i think there's a way through on meat
that actually
we as a country can navigate and still
have
the kind of landscapes that we enjoy so
much that make up such a big part of our
kind of cultural heritage i i suppose
the key question then mr tumblebee is
what is the likelihood of the government
listening to you in all of this
introducing a sugar tax a
assault tax reducing a reliance on junk
food
when you have in boris johnson a
populist in number 10.
well i think boris johnson's changed
right so uh
his experience during covid has
fundamentally changed the way he thinks
about
the food system and our need to do
something about it but kind of to answer
the question more broadly whenever you
do i've done
three nav independent reviews and
whenever you do one
uh you know that your your work is not
guaranteed to be taken up and so you do
everything you can to
communicate it in a simple way to bring
coalitions around the recommendations
and in the last two reviews that i've
done almost everything's been
uh implemented and i will be doing my
utmost to make the case
uh for the government to implement these
things which are doable
practical and we think will make a a
real transformation of the food system